I heard you like graham cracker so I
went dipped your graham crackers and
chocolate here to pimp your snack and I
never get to use my exhibit impression
because it's just not relevant anymore
stuff I didn't know he's like oh well
see that's why today we're gonna try all
of the pastries that they have for us at
Starbucks so it's not every single item
so please don't trash your comments
sometimes they're out like they usually
are with the stuff that I want and we
got what we got so more food than we
need but we gonna eat it yeah I know you
walked through a Starbucks you see so
many pastries like should I get it
should I get it what we're about to do
that work for you we're gonna tell you
whether you should get it or not or
maybe so we got our coffee let's see
this first thing first we got the bagel
Joyce is already splitting it up I mean
hey it's on my first run with a bagel
this is a classic you can go to a bagel
spot or you can come to Starbucks and
see what this stop back I love bagels so
you're a bagel head I mean I told you
I'm gonna see this bagel looks good the
crust could be a little bit harder this
is a decent bagel if you're running late
to your house during the day I'm not
gonna say that this is a solid bagel a
bagel from a cafe being this good like
you're at Starbucks you're there for the
coffee's I'm saying yeah great
accompaniment or you're or whatever
whatever Frappuccino
whatever whatever profit you know I'm
definitely stop making my bring this
when they come over my house got the
spout green table this off rip looks a
bit dryer I remember all that nasty-ass
bread my mom would buy did you know
she's like gotta be a healthy choice and
I would eat this bread and our insulin I
feel like the dryness they had nothing
to do with the bow it's always bass
things how much like quickly mix me okay
my mouth is excited you're excited for
the flu
I'll always be here to eat it'll make a
good healthy remaining
taste like weep but not fully still
gonna me yes because I feel like this is
like a preferential thing you know we're
not gonna order the red roll we're gonna
get that we troll you at me means you
like get the dark bread this is gonna be
for you we have the cinnamon raisin
bagel and your boy is hyped because I
love me a good sweet bagel the whole
bagel budget went into this service was
like look you could do whatever you want
with the plane but when you make the
cinnamon raisin and better slap it's a
yes for most oh yes yes this is a plane
for song we're about to get turnt up hey
we we oh yeah it's gonna be yes from us
I think that this is how just all
chocolate croissants I've come across
our wares just like the chocolate bar
inside and then when it toasts it's like
melty and good croissants are good at
any temperature all right a little
crunch of chocolate I always feel like
chocolate croissants or forced Wow it
doesn't mean you get to pass there's
gonna be an open I'm gonna say it maybe
we got a petite vanilla bean scones
scones are always real tricky for me
between the mouthfeel I feel like you
need a mouthful of our teeth there it is
right there took the bike we started to
get in the papaya biscuit territory
we're reading in there start sucking the
air out and then I took a sip not only
saved my life but it also complements
the flavors a pastry that complements
coffee that is served at a coffee place
is a perfect pairing
yeah which is a good choice I like how
its petite I like how it's vanilla bean
and I like oats it's gone but it's not
too dry yes yes yes Miami Starbucks kind
of sewer phone dump a lot of money card
holder essentially ship out to about
like 10 15 drinks and you got it for
free then now it's like a hundred
dollars you spent protip for any type of
cinnamon bun or scented roll-off that
95% of the bun I get took a little nice
can't piece he put his whole mouth on
this it's the middle like this is not
sharing opportunity he destroyed that
morning money is that obvious yes
because nine times out 10 I go to
Starbucks this is gone already and the
cheesecake or is the different I think
so yeah this is delicious and nutritious
since this is a little coffee at the
coffee shop and you know this that tall
and II like alternative white guy
staring at me and then we start talking
about our favorite books
protip just eat around the middle she's
got that last bite I've never been the
biggest fan but looking at the way these
cinnamon crystals in the middle or
topping right now I might change my mind
very moist coffee cake man he loves
moist can we get a count of how many
times you said moist right up
I mean when you go to the page freeze
moist is one of the best qualities you
need to keep it moist you're going to
Hollywood
that's a guest for me dog wow he's so
fake when the cameras were off no I'm
not into coffee cake
I say yes to is delicious I'm going to
part it for him better so that I don't
hear a comment for this man go for the
bell cake but you're not even going
towards the icing which is arguably the
best spot let me get this part with
either you move oh my god that wasn't
like on purpose it's nice and spongy
it's a perfect pounding yeah
[Applause]
yes we have a banana map generator this
will be infinite stick it ain't sick I
took a small bite because this is a lot
for me it's a lot of sugar but this is
lat oh yeah I'm into it like what's her
name what's her number what's their sign
yeah I think any of the cakes shaped
like this at Starbucks is a safe bet
yeah I'll go buddy yes yes yeah now
we're in the interesting territory cuz
it felt like we kicked off no like we
kicked off the video in the breakfast
territory now we're talking about
afternoon delights
brownies like that 3 p.m. and on your
last break at work and it'll pick me up
it's a pretty good decent like mocha
chocolate brownie this is a guess for me
but I don't think it's his first stop so
I'm gonna down rich roommate officially
my answer is yes okay she's in a coke
bottle okay no let a lot of analogies
ban that one makes no sense whatsoever
they did a great job I like the
thickness of it nice and warm would make
a nice gooey gooey a good chocolate chip
cookie has that like extra seasoning we
like is it not man yeah yeah and this
does have that and that's what I was
looking for when I took a bite in there
because like that's what's gonna take it
to the next level I think the cookies
great I do think they made it a little
too sweet probably have this with lunch
as a dessert or an afternoon pick-me-up
I'm gonna give a full one yes five years
ago yeah like right around when these
were released I cake pops were on a roll
everybody one
[Music]
[Music]
the only answer is yes I don't think I'd
ever buy biscotti from a Starbucks
especially packaged like this like maybe
if I went to a place that like handmade
it I'd go for it but this no they're
very like saw it has a nice buttery
flavor they're small enough you can like
have one now a few later oh my god yes
this time I'm gonna put it in the maybe
pile cause like I like it it's not
enough
hey yo homie I heard you like Madeline
so I wouldn't dip those Madeline's in
chocolate with empty Oh Madeline's do
any of y'all remember exhibit look at
him we eat a whole but now he's giving
me
oh man oh yeah i heard you like graham
cracker so I went dipped your graham
crackers and chocolate here to pee all
the time yeah I don't work means finger
muscles oh well alright I'll keep it
it's a good snack but like a Starbucks
specialty the price for this probably
just is just a little too high so you
know what everyone is eating their big
sweets I can have this nice dark
chocolate so yeah so I'm gonna give it a
guess for that it's a made one for me
yeah we got Walker shortbread cookie I
love a good shortbread with coffee so
this one is gonna change you eat a lot
of damn patients let sit down coffee I
will join my coffee straight full of
regrets you ever go to your grandma's
house you see that for Luton and you
open it and there's some materials in it
this tastes like the cookies that used
to be in there which are shortbread
cookies this one actually I like more
because those cookies are really hard
this one is like nice and soft so this
is gonna be a yes for me I should go
with him from one so it's a hundred
stands for man alright so I know I said
I was gonna help you out but it looks
like I liked almost all of it so that's
gonna make it a lot harder for me but
what it seems like whatever you choose
you're gonna be in a good place and
don't think too hard though what your
guys go what you want go it's all gonna
be Gucci because they're still paying
for it
[Music]